[Applaudissements]
parlez-moi de la pluie et non pas du
beau temps le beau temps me dégoûte et
me fait grincer les
d le Bel Azur me met en rage car le plus
grand amour qui me fut donné sur terre
je le dois au mauvais temps je le dois à
Jupiter il me tombe d'un ciel
d'orage par un soir de novembre à cheval
sur les toits un vrai tonur de breste
avec des cris
butoir allumer ses feux
d'artifice bissant de sa couche en
costume de nuit ma voisine a follé
vincogniè à mon nuit en réclamant mes
bons
offices je suis seul et j'ai peur
ouvrez-moi par pitié mon épou vient de
partir faire son dur métier pauvre
malheure
mercire cont train de coucher dehors
quand il fait mauvais temps pour la
bonne raison qu'il est
représentant d'une maison de
paratenire en bénissant le nom de
Benjamin Franklin je l'ai mise en lieu
sûr entre mes bras câin
et puis l'amour a fait le reste toi qui
SME des partenaires à foison que
nanaastu planté sur ta propre maison
l'reur on ne peut plus
funeste quand Jupiter alla se faire
entendre ailleurs la belle ayant enfin
conjuré sa frayur et recouvrait tout son
courage rentra dans ses foyers faire
sécher son mari en me donnant
rendez-vous les jours d'un tempée
rendez-vous au prochaine
orage à partir de ce jour je n'ai plus
baissé les yeux j'ai consacré mon temps
à contempler les cieux à regarder passer
les nu à guetter les stratus à lorgner
les Nimbus à faire les yeux doux au
moindre cumulus mais elle n'est pas
revenue son bonhomme de Marie avait tant
fait d'affaire tant vendu ce soir-là de
petits bouts de fer il était devenu
millionnaire l'avait emmené vers les
cieux toujours bleus les pays imbéciles
où jamais il ne pleut où l'on ne sait
rien du
tonner ne fasse que ma complainte aille
tambour battant lui parler de la pluie
lui parler du gros temps auquel on a du
tête ensemble je compter qu'un certain
coup de poudre assassin dans le mil de
mon cœur à laisser le
dessin une petite fleur qui lui
[Musique]
ressemble